dans ce stage de danse ils sont une
cinquantaine de mômes de 7 à 17 ans tous
du même quartier de bourj résulte de la
chancellerie
un même quartier pour des enfants
d'origines très diverses puisque 1 sur 4
à des parents émigrés mais là où
certains se bloque d'autres peuvent-ils
voir au contraire une chance celle de
l'émergence d'un dialogue d'une
communauté alors ce dialogue
c'est le but que se sont fixé deux
jeunes maghrébins mais en france ceux de
la deuxième génération et qui se nomme
que même en verlan les beurs et c'est
d'avoir participé à la marche contre le
racisme dont cent mille personnes à
paris qui a donné envie à ces jeunes
berruyers d'agir contre le racisme le
rejet
nous avons eu envie que l'esprit de la
marche pour l'égalité et contre le
racisme que se perpétue et c'est nous
allons commencer donc par l'elysée
quelques soirées débats sur la zup de
bronze jaunards et l'idée nous est venue
d'organiser un mois pour l'égalité et
contre le racisme à rebours votre
volonté c'est de d'insérer les
communautés immigrées dans la communauté
française
est-ce que et cela avec et france et non
pas contre est ce que est ce que vous
allez du répondant du côté français ben
nous essayons qui a duré pendant pense
qu'il ya eu quelques français qui
répondent à notre appel mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya beaucoup de problème
aujourd'hui est que l'on se rend compte
que même au bout ans le racisme existe
puisque dernièrement nous avons vu un
certain nombre d'inscriptions racistes
sur les le centre-ville
cette volonté de dialogue surtout bien
sûr des obstacles prévisible en témoigne
en effet quelques incidents récents ou
encore les courageux coup de téléphone
anonyme dont sont victimes ceux des
français qui font de leur côté un
premier pas là pour quatre ans
et je pense que il faut qu'on arrive à
évacuer bon ça naît ça vous pose de
problème sur votre parti le racisme
beaucoup même damas à mi temps à faire
de nouvelles connaissances pour moi et
certainement des amis aussi et c'est
très important contre le racisme match
de foot intercommunautés participation
la marche bourges sancerre soirées
débats expositions et puis surtout ce
stage de danse animée par elodie sheryfa
chorégraphe algérien venu tout
spécialement à danseurs de premier ordre
et qui initie au folk en maghrébins les
gosses de toutes origines qui souhaitent
asiatique français ou espagnol ne les
désavantages d'ailleurs pas par rapport
à leurs camarades arabe
ces derniers découvrent eux aussi ce qui
n'est que culturel un rythme qui leur
est tout aussi étrangers puisque ce sont
avant tout pas ou bronzer et qu'on le
veuille ou non des berrichons les
berrichons ouvert à des voyages et des
danses désormais possible à portée de
main